The standard error we've been using assumes that the samples are approximately
the same size. We must correct for the sample size first by pooling the
variances. So now, we're going to slightly change the standard error that we've
been using. The pooled variance, which we'll denote S sub p squared, because
remember that S squared was the variance and S was the standard deviation, is
the average of the two sample variances that corrects for different sample
sizes. Remember when we had one sample that the variance was the sum of squares
divided by the degrees of freedom, which written out is the sum of this squared
deviations divided by n minus 1. With pooled variances, we're doing almost the
same thing. When we have two samples, we'll add the sum of squares for each,
and then divide by the sum of the degrees of freedom. Let's go through an
example. Let's say we have two samples, which we'll call x and y. We want to
know if the populations that these samples are from are significantly
different. First, find the sum of squares for each. Remember that to do this
you'll have to find each deviation from the mean, and then, square them, and
then add them up. You're welcome to write each deviation and squared deviation
in these columns, but you don't have to. We just provide the boxes there, so
that that can help you as you calculate the sum of squares. But you can always
use technology, Excel or R/g, or whatever you want to use. Or you can just do
it by hand rather than typing them in. Whatever is easiest, as long as you get
these sum of squares.